I hear you're a serious gamer oh yeah
you're a very serious gamer and that you
get very passionate when you're playing
video games yeah now I play a fair share
of video games how intense do you get I
mean I go crazy I play lots of online
games mostly Call of Duty I got a clan
called SMG sex money and guns and when
we come through you know you just might
as well lay down cuz we come in through
laying people down I like the online
shooters how intense do you get when you
go crazy I'm in the house I'm screaming
and stuffing the funny thing it's like
I'm screaming at the TV like you knew
you camping but see you know like yeah
yeah you're flat now get flat sucker so
I'm talking and Coco's on the phone with
her friends and she they hear me yelling
they're like is everything okay I know
you're explosion sudden that's the ice
is playing games and they're like what
kind of game you must go insane when you
beat a level that was tough to class you
know of anybody who watch the show ice
loves Coco nose I had this particular
thing I would do when I would win a
level it's called the dick dance
you and a friend named dick would get
together and dance uh actually I mean
some of the levels I don't know y'all
don't may not play games but some of
these levels are so intense that you
just can't win and you sometimes have to
go to sleep thinking about them like
until the next day or either you go and
you cheat you get the books but when you
finally win you're so excited so I would
stand up in my house unzip my pants and
do the dick dance without a dick it kind
of looks like this
[Applause]
put video yeah sure with a bit yeah yeah
get that out of my face
and it's liberating its out for it when
that happens do Coco's friends say
what's that say yeah unfortunately
doesn't make that much story don't tie a
bell do it or something
the enhance oh my god I'd get pyro going
I'd get a whole you get pyro go yeah
you'd strap firecrackers sparklers
sparklers now that's not happening homey
nah nah next time you do the dance fly
sparklers to it no what happens now no
fire around that area
you